can you make the case for and against
the the hunter Biden laptop story for it
being a big deal and against it being a
big deal sure so so the case for it
being a big deal is basically twofold
one is that it is clearly relevant if
the president's son is running around to
foreign countries picking up bags of
cash because his last name is Biden well
his father is Vice President of the
United States and it raises questions as
to influence peddling for either the
vice president or the former vice
president using political connections
did he make any money who was the big
guy right all these open questions that
obviously implicates you know the
questions to be asked and then the
secondary reason that the story is big
is actually because the reaction of the
story The Banning of the story is in and
of itself a major story if there's if
there's any story that implicates a
presidential candidate in the last month
of an election and there is a media
blackout
including a social media blackout that
obviously raises some very serious
questions about informational flow and
dissemination in the United States so no
matter how big of a deal the story is it
is a big deal that there's a censorship
of any relevance when there's a
coordinated collusive blackout yeah
that's that's a serious and major
problem uh so those are the two reasons
why it would be a big story the two
reasons a reason why it would not be a
big story perhaps uh is if it turns out
and we don't really know this yet but
let's say that Hunter Biden was
basically off on his own doing what he
was doing you know being a derelict or a
drug addict or acting badly uh and his
dad had nothing to do with it and Joe
was telling the truth and he really but
the problem is we never actually got
those questions answered so if it turned
out to be nothing of a story the nice
thing about stories that turn out to be
nothing is that after they turn out to
be nothing they're nothing the biggest
problem with this story is that it
wasn't allowed to take the normal life
cycle of a story which is original story
breaks follow-on questions are asked
follow-on questions are answered story
is either now a big story or into
nothing one when the life cycle of a
story is cut off right at the very
beginning right when it's born then that
allows you to speculate in any direction
you want you can speculate it means
nothing it's nonsense it's Russian it's
a Russian laptop it's it's
disinformation or on the other hand this
means that Joe Biden was personally
calling Hunter and telling him to pick
up a sack of cash over in Beijing and
then you can press it and he's influence
pedaling so you know this is why it's
important to allow these stories to go
forward so this is why actually the
bigger story for the moment is not the
laptop It's the reaction to the laptop
because it cut off that life cycle of
the story
and then you know at some point I would
assume that there will be some follow-on
questions that are actually answered I
mean the house is pledging if it goes
Republican to investigate all of this
again I wouldn't be supremely surprised
if it turns out that that there was no
direct involvement of Joe in this sort
of stuff because it turns out as I said
before that all of politics is Veep and
this is this is always the story with
half the scandals that you see is that
everybody assumes that there's some sort
of deep and abiding clever plan that
some politician is implementing it and
then you look at it and it turns out now
it's just something dumb right this sort
of perfect example of this you know
president Trump with the classified
documents in Mar-A-Lago so people on the
left leg it's probably nuclear codes
probably he's taking secret documents
and selling them to the Russians or the
Chinese and the real most obvious
explanation is Trump looked at the
papers and he said I like these papers
and then he just decided to keep them
right and then people came in and said
Mr President you're not allowed to keep
those papers he said who are those
people I don't care about what they have
to say I'm putting them in the other
room in a box
like like Which is my
it is it is highly likely that that is
what happened and it's very
disappointing to people I think when
they realize it the human brain I mean
you know this better than I do but the
human brain is built to find patterns
right it's what we like to do we like to
find plans and patterns because this is
how we survived in the wild is you found
a plan you found a pattern
you crack the code of the universe when
it comes to politics the the conspiracy
theories that we see so often it's
largely because we're seeing
inexplicable events unless you just
assume everyone's a [ __ ] if you assume
that there's a lot of stupidity going on
everything becomes quickly explicable if
you assume that that there must be some
rationale behind it you have to come up
with increasingly convoluted conspiracy
theories to explain just why people are
acting in the way that they're acting
and I find that I don't say 100 of the
time but 90 94 of the time the The
Conspiracy Theory turns out just to be
people being dumb and then other people
reacting in Dumb Ways to the original
people being dumb but it's also to me in
that same way very possible uh very
likely that the hunter Biden Hunter
Biden getting money in Ukraine I guess
for Consulting all that kind of stuff is
as a nothing Burger is uh he's qualified
he's getting money as he should there's
a lot of influence peddling in general
in terms that's not corrupt I think the
most obvious explanation there probably
is that he was
fake influence pedaling meaning he went
to Ukraine and he's like guess what my
dad's Joe and they're like well you
don't have any qualifications in oil and
natural gas and you don't really have a
great resume but your dad is Joe and
then that was kind of the end of it they
gave him a bag of cash hoping he would
do something he never did anything I
think you're making it sound worse than
it is I think this in general Consulting
is done in that way your name it's not
like you're with you you're not it's not
like he is some rare case and this is an
illustration of corruption if you can
criticize consulting which I would
that's fair which they're basically not
providing
you look at a resume and who's who like
if you went to Harvard I can criticize
the same thing if if you have Harvard on
your resume you're more likely to be
hired as a consultant maybe there's a
network there of people that you know
and you hire them in that same way if
your last name is Biden if you're last
there's a lot of last names that sound
pretty good for sure for sure and it's
not like I committed that much by the
way right an open interview he was like
if your last name Warren bite when you
got that job and he's like probably not
it's not like he's getting a ridiculous
amount of money he was getting like a
pretty standard Consulting kind of money
which also would criticize because they
get a ridiculous amount of money but I
sort of even to push back on the life
cycle or to steal Madness the the side
that was concerned about the hunter
behind laptop story I don't know if
there is a natural life cycle of a story
because there's something about the
virality of the internet that we can't
predict that a story can just
take hold and the conspiracy around it
builds especially around politics where
the interpretation
some popular sexy interpretation of a
story that might not be connected to
reality at all will become viral and
that from Facebook's perspective is
probably what they're worried about is
uh uh organized misinformation campaign
that makes up a sexy story or sexy
interpretation of the of the vague story
that we have and that has an influence
on the populace I mean I think that's
true but I think the question becomes
who's the great adjudicator there right
who adjudicates when the story ought to
be allowed to go through even a bad life
cycle or a lab allowed to go viral as
opposed to not now it's one thing if you
want to say okay we can spot the Russian
accounts that are actually promoting
this stuff they belong to the Russian
government gotta shut that down I think
everybody agrees this is actually one of
the slides that's happened
linguistically that I really object to
is the slide between disinformation and
misinformation you notice there's this
Evolution and in 2017 there's a lot of
talk about disinformation there's
Russian disinformation the Russians were
putting out deliberately false
information in order to skew election
results was the accusation and then
people started using disinformation or
misinformation and misinformation is
either mistaken information or
information that is quote unquote out of
context that becomes very subjective
very quickly as to what out of context
means and it doesn't necessarily have to
be from a foreign Source it can be from
a domestic Source right it could be
somebody misintered doing something here
it could be somebody interpreting
something correctly but PolitiFact
thinks that it's out of context and that
that sort of stuff gets very murky very
quickly and so I'm deeply uncomfortable
with the idea that Facebook I mean
Zuckerberg was was on with Rogan and
talking about how you know the FBI had
basically set lookout for Russian
interference in the election and then
all of these people were out there
saying that the laptop was Russian
disinformation so he basically shut it
down you know that that sort of stuff is
frightening especially because it wasn't
Russian disinformation I mean the laptop
was real and so the the fact that you
have people who seemed to let's put this
right it seems as though maybe this is
wrong it seems as though when a story
gets killed preemptively like this it is
almost universally a story that
negatively affects one side of the
political aisle I can't remember the
last time there's a story on the right
that was disinformation or
misinformation where social media
stepped in and they went we cannot have
this this cannot be distributed we're
going to all colludes that this this
information is not distributed maybe in
response to the story being proof false
it gets taken down but the what made the
hunter Biden thing so amazing is that it
wasn't relieved in response to anything
it was like the story got posted there
were no actual doubts expressed
as to the verified falsity of the story
it was just supposition that it had to
be false and everybody jumped in so I
think that confirmed a lot of the
conspiracy theories people had about
about social media and how it works yeah
so if the reason you want to slow down
the viral spread of a thing is at all
grounded in partisanship that's a
problem like you should be very honest
with yourself and ask yourself that
question is it because I'm on the left
or on the right that I want to slow this
down versus is it hate
uh bipartisan hate speech
right so that that's but it's really
it's really tricky
um but I I like you I'm very
uncomfortable in general but then you're
kind of slowing down with any kind of
censorship but if if there's something
like a conspiracy theory that spreads
hate
that becomes viral
um I still lean to let that conspiracy
theory spread
because the alternative is dangerous and
more dangerous it's sort of like the
ring of power right like everybody wants
the ring because with the ring you can
stop the bad guys from going forward but
it turns out that the ring
gives you enormous power and that power
can be used in the wrong ways too